our car credit Christa Bauer is in wolfs
Borges Car Museum
looking for an interesting car to try
out of the 200 automotive milestones on
display his attention is drawn to a
revolutionary design that flopped on the
market
and as Hugh's ROA T introduced in 1967
the futuristic sedan featured a number
of groundbreaking innovations it was the
first German automobile to win Europe's
Car of the Year award Cristo says NSU
which until then had only made small
cars built the ROA T as a full-fledged
attempt at an upmarket midsize car it
had a rotary engine a futuristic design
front-wheel drive fully independent
suspension and disc brakes on each wheel
all the ingredients for success
it seemed ns used marketing campaign
invited comparison with the established
players here a proud new owner tells us
friendly car has amazing aerodynamics
NSU gambled that the rotary engine and
advanced aerodynamics would be enough to
challenge Mercedes and BMW the
advantages of the rotary piston engine
are that it produces very little
vibration and has good revving power
unfortunately the engine also had
chronic problems many owners had to
replace engines after less than 20,000
kilometers Christoph says people used to
joke that drivers had a special greeting
to show how many engines their car had
already gone through and in fact the
engine did initially have bugs NSU had
to replace so many for free that the
company's accountants were in shock but
by 1970 the engine problems had been
solved this car from 1977
still purrs sweetly with its original
engine
rotary engines get their power from high
engine speed instead of engine size the
RO atntion displaced just one liter but
produced 115 horsepower and had a top
speed of 180 kilometers an hour this 45
year old car feels almost as civilized
as a modern car well almost
it's destined off to puff T a loud bang
from the exhaust leads christophe to
remarked that this car seems to think
it's a rocket he says that although it's
not especially sporty it is a great
looking car features like the low wedge
like shape and sharply raked windshield
which is great for the aerodynamics
catch the eye but the most distinctive
touch for Christoph is this crease that
goes all the way around the car and
gives it a tidy elegance that tidiness
ends under the hood however we're a nest
of pipes and hoses hides the little
rotary engine does it stuff that can't
even claim or track the smooth body
shape gave the car a drag coefficient of
0.35 which was sensational at the time
and better than that of a modern day out
er8 sports car
the interior is straightforward and
unpretentious an automatic transmission
power steering and the big cushy seats
make it a comfortable car for longer
trips
the engine is mounted low which gives
the car a low center of gravity that
makes the aerodynamic shape possible but
there's one other problem rotary engines
in general are not very fuel-efficient
and tooling around these country roads
in Tuscany the roa t burns up 17 litres
of gasoline for every 100 kilometres the
transmission doesn't help
the RO ad has a semi-automatic
transmission there's no clutch pedal so
the driver just moves the gearshift to
change gears christophe says that takes
some getting used to but it works fine
the only problem is the automatic shift
slowly and there's not much torque so
even with 115 horsepower it's not a very
sporty car rock solid v tempest
michelada an aspartic angling that
accelerating from 0 to 100 takes about
14 seconds which wasn't bad for a sedan
in the late 60s but the rotary engines
performance makes driving the car a
fairly unexcited endeavor
instead the roa t feels sedate and
distinguished
Evelyn Sunita Hamza it's not easy being
a revolutionary Christophe says that
while the ROA T was a failure at the
time its futuristic design and the
rotary engine make it one of the most
advanced cars of the 60s for our tester
it marks a milestone and the development
of the modern automobile